hello we have just restocked the
microcosmos microscope over at
microcosmos.store and we now have two
models available one that comes with
achromatic objectives and the other that
comes with plan achromatic objectives
and if you've previously purchased a
macro Cosmos microscope and would like
to upgrade your objectives from
acrobatic to plan we have a four pack of
plan objectives on sale as well as two
brand new 20x and 60x plan objectives
you can get all of that and more now at
microcosmos.store
foreign
[Music]
because we are just too excited about
today's episode if you've been following
James our master of microscopes on some
of his other platforms then you know
what's coming you know that James has
published his first academic paper which
was co-authored by Dr Dimitra Andrea and
James's Mentor Professor genoveva F
Esteban if you want to find it you can
just look for the article titled the
extraordinarily rare ciliate legendre
loyase in the journal protest we'll
leave a link for it down below the paper
is as you might be able to tell from the
title about this extraordinarily rare
ciliate that you see on the screen now
called legendre Eloise just how rare is
this ciliate it's so rare that before
James stumbled on some of his own it had
only been reported by four other people
ever
there are a vast number of microbe
species in the world so many in fact
that it seems like a miracle that we are
able to find the same species twice some
of these species are incredibly prolific
reproducing at rates that make them
impossible to ignore under the
microscope but then there are the
microbes who turn up once in a blue moon
like mythical creatures of the
microcosmos whose life seems to exist
only in a few lines of text and the rare
illustrations that preserve them
the first record of legendre Loya's
existence came in 1908 from a French
scientist named Emmanuel Flores fremier
he had been Gathering samples from a
pond near Paris studying the mud for
what he described as infusoria a name
once used to describe microbes and among
the organisms that he found were just a
few of these ovalish creatures with one
elongated macronucleus and roughly 20
tentacles of varying length that
branched out from their bodies he named
the creature legendre Eloise and he
never explained why
only six years later a Swiss biologist
named Eugene penard reported finding
legendrea lawyers in his own samples
this time from Geneva but he didn't just
stop with legendre Eloy as a panard
bound six other species that he believed
should belong to the genus including
this one which he named legendre
belaraphan there were a few
characteristics that made panard
consider this a new separate species but
the most important factor were legendre
belaraphan's tentacles which pinard
described as being more like quote
sessile pimples that could extend and
retract in comparison he said legendrea
lawyers a were not capable of the
controlled extension that legendre of
belaraphan are instead their tentacles
trail behind them as they swim through
the water
Alfred call the prolific documenter of
ciliate Life reported his description of
legendre Eloise in 1930 but after that
they seemed to go unnoticed in the
microcosmos until
2014. when a microscopist named Martin
Cruz found them lurking in German ponds
and across all of these descriptions
were slight contradictions differences
in how they perceived the cell's
morphology that were really difficult to
resolve with so few observations but
even in those large gaps of time where
scientists weren't finding legendre
Eloise they were not forgotten in 1967
the scientist a w jenkowski decided to
take an ax to the legendread genus
splitting it into three
the distinction was based on the
placement of the organism's tentacles
legendrea like legendrea lawyers a who
had tentacles at the end of the cell
would remain legendrea those who had
tentacles only halfway in a row around
the cell would become lesseris and those
who had extendable tentacles in a row
that goes around the cell would be
called thyssanamorpha and that is how
legendre belaraphan became
thysanamorphobal arafin
it is not clear why Jankowski made this
decision to split legendre into three
Genera nor is it clear why it was
accepted in the official taxonomic codes
Jankowski didn't seem to have made any
observations of his own to decide these
differences instead using the
discrepancies in the rare existing
observations to make vast changes in
taxonomy without accounting for other
possibilities but that all brings us up
to 2021 and the discovery of another
possibility
more specifically it brings us to James
equipped with a plastic bottle a
microscope and an endless Devotion to
his craft
visiting two lakes around Warsaw James
carefully gathered samples from the
bottom of the lakes and stored them in
the dark with lids shut tight to
minimize the amount of oxygen coming in
so that the anaerobic organisms that
live in these sediments could thrive
and when he went to see what was hiding
within his samples we found four
legendre Eloise he immediately
recognized it from the pages of his
beloved ciliate reference books and was
thrilled to tell his mentor Professor
Esteban but the most surprising thing
would come later and a microscope slide
James sealed off with petroleum jelly so
that he could watch this legendre a
loyoza for longer he'd been watching it
swim around its tentacles trailing
behind and he kept the slide in a
humidity chamber and returned to it over
several days watching as it settled down
among some debris it was clearly alive
because there was some movement in the
cytoplasm but it just didn't move even
when James lightly tapped the slide or
shined a strong light onto it but after
four days something strange happened
this green euglena had wandered close to
the legendrea Too Close apparently for
the legendrea's comfort causing it to
contract its tentacles we still don't
know what exactly set the legendrea into
action but the most likely explanation
is that the euglena was releasing oxygen
into the water discomforting the
anaerobic legendrea
what caught James and Professor
esteban's notice was that legendary
Eloise seemed to not only control the
length of its tentacles but also the
location and as they extended and
contracted their tentacles the
organism's shape changed when extended
the tentacles appeared towards the side
of the swollen organism when contracted
at the tentacles sprouted from the end
of a heart-shaped cell no one had ever
observed this tentacle extension in
legendre Eloy as a before and more
importantly this movement seems to
explain the differences between the
descriptions of legendrea lawyers made
by earlier scientists the different
shapes they observed were likely
legendre Eloise in different states of
tentacle contraction and this is really
meaningful because it muddles the
reasoning behind jankowski's division of
the legendrea which was derived in part
on a static understanding of the
tentacles and as James argues in the
paper it means that dysanomorpha
bellerophin should become legendrea
belaraphan once
these observations that James made with
his microscope revealed a lot about a
rare species but there are depth that
the microscope cannot reach information
hidden in places we need other
techniques to reach we'll talk about
that in our next episode
and who knows with more observation and
more data perhaps there will be more
species reverted back to the legendrea
genus because that's sort of the point
of science there is no end to what we
know and what we will learn
there is simply a patient dedication to
the work to visiting the same Pond week
after week to watching the same sample
day after day to digging through old
books and forgotten texts until they are
embedded in memory we do love quoting a
microscopist here on Journey to the
microcosmos so perhaps we should pay
tribute to our own master of microscopes
and the ending of his paper
we hope that the study here presented
inspires the readership to spend more
time looking through a microscope and
reminding them that science is done to
subside the mind's curiosity not to
incite Discord in one's rather short
lifespan
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us no matter what we are
doing we are always communicating it's
how we make meaning of our surroundings
and interactions Communications is
ingrained in our daily interactions and
even if you feel like you're a great
communicator it's still important to
understand that communication is a
really complex social process that can
change depending on a wide array of
factors and that's why there is study
hall human communication the series
where they explore communication unpack
why it matters in our lives and teaches
you how to become an even better
Communicator they'll walk you through
the skills needed to be a good friend
student employee leader and Problem
Solver and help you better understand
how communication can impact your
relationships with people so check out
study hall human communication at the
link in the description
the people on the screen right now they
are our patreon patrons they support
this channel as we explore this
wonderful world of ours that has so many
secrets in it that are just waiting to
be uncovered and in this video we
actually got to talk about a secret that
was uncovered by our master of
microscopes which is really remarkable
so I want to say thank you very much to
all these people who support so that
everybody can enjoy and if you would
like to become one of them you can go to
patreon.com journey to micro if you want
to see more from our master of
microscopes you can check out jam and
germs on Instagram and if you want to
see more from us there's always a
subscribe button somewhere nearby
[Music]